I think that we ill prepare athletes
from the very beginning from the moment
they pick up a ball or kick it or
whatever it is they're doing we will
prepare them especially with the major
sports what you see is this cycle of
entitlement that gets thrown their way
so you know the kid who's in junior high
and hasn't finished his test but still
gets to play because you know athlete
fails the test and still gets to play
because they're an athlete gets to get
away with not doing chores at home
because they've got practice all these
types of things build up and then in
college I love college and I and I think
you know many colleges aren't as good as
the one that I went to in terms of
taking care of the whole athlete and
they focus on weightlifting and practice
and and academically they just let you
get by you know I went to Penn State
nobody was allowed to just get by you
know they wanted academic all-americans
if they could have them but that's not
the case everywhere and then you get to
be a pro and all of a sudden a lot of
things are possible for you that are
impossible for anybody else you know the
fact is that I know I've been stopped
more than a handful of times by the
police for driving just a little bit too
fast and I've never had a ticket in this
country never had a ticket because I
signed plenty of tickets for police
officers but I haven't actually been
given a ticket so all of a sudden if
you're not careful this feeling comes
over you that you are a bit omnipotent
you can do anything and this is a really
dangerous combination once the adulation
stops it's really dangerous paired with
that and I think maybe it even more
important is the fact that when I play
basketball I never thought I was a
basketball player I played basketball I
was a man who played basketball and
after I played basketball and before I
play basketball I was going to be a
psychologist whereas most people who
play their occupation is their
definition and then when they stop doing
who they are they become nothing
and that's what you see so many of these
problems with their desperate to try and
find a new way to be relevant even to
themselves so this combination of
entitlement and then the fact that when
your career is over you stop being
relevant even to yourself is just deadly
we've got to educate athletes not only
in the pros with great programs that
need to be implemented but in college
and in high school and even before